So, I think we are to begin on February 17th, 1922, is that right?
Yes.
Okay.
So, the message here is love is everything.
Love is the center of everything, it's all about love, and nothing is more important
than love, because God is love.
Now, this message has been given a number of times in the volumes leading up to this.
Every now and then the Lord comes back to this, that the center of everything is love.
So, but in case you have forgotten, it's one Corinthians 13, the whole chapter.
Love is patient, kind, and all the rest of it.
One Corinthians 14, one, you must want love more than anything else.
John 13, 34 to 35, you are to love one another, as I love you.
And Ephesians 3, 16 to 21, built on love, you grow in love, you reach full maturity
and love until you reach the full measure of Christ, Ephesians 3, 16 to 21.
So, Louisa said, "I felt all oppressed because of the privation of my sweet Jesus, and I
did nothing but call him, desire him, but in vain.
After much hardship, when I could take no more, he came.
I call that the cliffhanger move."
Now, you're about to fall off the cliff, and then he comes.
But he's now going to explain why he waits until we consider it the last minute, okay?
So, who knows how many things I wanted to tell him, but he rose up high without giving
me time, and I looked at him and called him, "Jesus, Jesus, come."
He too looked at me and let a Jew reign upon me from his person, so Jew fell from him
unto Louisa, which beaded all of me.
This Jew drew him towards me.
Now notice he's showing her that something has got to draw him towards her, and she sees
it as a Jew coming from him.
So it drew him towards me in such a way that he lowered himself towards me and told me.
Now, this is the very important thing.
He's going to explain the importance of desire if you really want God.
He needs to know you actually do want him, because sometimes, you know, we can pray in
such a way that he doesn't actually know whether you want him or not.
I'm sure you've often said to a child, "Do you really want it?"
Because the person has not communicated that they really want it.
My daughter, he said, "The desire of the soul to see me tears the veil which exists between
time and eternity."
And her repeated desire makes her take flight to come close to me.
So why does he not come immediately?
He says that if he doesn't come immediately, her desire goes deeper and deeper to the point
where she can actually get him to break through to our dimension.
My love is almost restless until I see that the soul yearns for me.
Now that's a big problem that God has, how many people don't want him at all.
And people who think that they want him may not, in fact, want him that badly.
So because of this, I do not make myself seen.
And only then does she calm herself, that is when the Lord shows himself, when I not
only make myself seen, but I give her new carisms and new pledges of love.
Because the Lord never comes empty-handed, okay?
He always comes with gifts.
And then he says, "My love is always in the act of wanting to give new pledges of love
to the creature."
So he is in the position of always wanting to give.
But we're now always in the position of wanting to receive.
And as soon as it sees that my will takes the operating and directing role of giving itself
to the creature, my love makes feasts, runs, flies to her, and becomes the cradle of man.
Now this image is a bit unusual for Louisa.
Think of an infant in a cradle, okay?
So my love becomes the cradle of man.
And if it sees that she does not rest in its cradle, it rocks her and sings to her to
make her rest and sleep on its lap.
So the image is of a parent with a very small infant, okay?
A Sam 131, the whole of it, it's only a few verses.
And it's Sam 61, which repeats four or five times, rest in God, my soul.
My hope comes from him.
So and while she sleeps, it breathes upon her into her mouth to give her the new life
of love.
So there you have the sleep of contemplation that the soul is actually resting in God.
If it sees from her interrupted breath that her heart is not happy, by sending her its
breath, my love forms the cradle for her within her heart so as to take bitterness and hindrance
and bothers away from her.
Again, the image is of a mother with an infant in her arms and whatever is disturbing the
child, the mother fixes.
Now St. Therese of Lissie was very good on that she used to actually genuinely sleep
during prayer as well because they were praying at God knows what hour in the morning, three
or four in the morning.
And she was very ill.
And one of the nuns asked her, did she not have a problem about it?
And she said, no, I'm sleeping in his arms, he's not asleep.
If he was asleep, I'd have a problem.
She was very wise and she was able to really cut to the chase very quickly, okay?
And then the Lord said, and when the soul wakes up, oh, how my love rejoices in seeing
her reborn, happy and full of life.
Now notice, we plunge ourselves into his love, which is our cradle of life.
And what he wants is to enable us to be transformed and reborn.
So you'll always know if it's God around, you're continuously improving.
You'll know if it's somebody else that's around because you're dis-improving.
And so you have that as a discernment.
So love says to her, see, I rocked you on my lap to give you a rest.
I kept vigil like a mother at your side during your sleep so that you might wake up strong
and happy and completely different from the one you were.
In other words, if we truly rest in God, we are guaranteed to be transformed.
Now, he doesn't transform you overnight because we're not able to take it, but he does it
gradually.
Oh, I've just remembered that transformation is two Corinthians 3 18.
You wouldn't think I prepared this today, would you?
Two Corinthians 3 18 says that you become like what you worship.
So if you're cradled in the arms of love and transformed by love, then you become a very
loving person.
Okay, you become an image of that love.
Now I want to be a cradle.
Watch this now for your steps, for your works, for your words and for everything.
Think that you are being rocked by me and place your love in the cradle of my love so that
identifying ourselves with each other, we may make each other happy.
That's where these prayers, we put our movements and steps and all the rest of it into the
divine will.
Be careful not to put anything else in the cradle because the Lord is very jealous.
The cradle is divine love.
So divine love won't take anything that's outside of itself.
That's Hebrews 12, 14, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
Do you remember that one?
What would be the thing that we might put into the cradle without even thinking about
it?
It's a little bit of our self, it's a little bit of self, okay?
So because you said if you put something else in and the thing we're dealing with all the
time is handing over our will so it's our ego that wants stuff for itself.
So be careful you don't put anything else otherwise you would sat in me and you'd make
me cry bitterly.
That's him using Louis' language, okay?
The way St. Paul would put it is that you would grieve the Lord, you would grieve the
Holy Spirit, okay?
So in the next section what he wants to tell us is that you were created in love.
You were to be conceived in love, you were to be nurtured in love, you were to be born
in love, you were to be reared in love, you were to consecrate love in marriage and you
were to die in love and be with love forever.
It's all about love, okay?
So he wants to tell us that the destiny of the human race is love.
So if we don't pass the test of love we haven't passed the central test of life.
So he says, "My love is that which comes closest to man, even more it is the cradle
in which he was born, although everything is in harmony with my divinity just as the
members are in full harmony with the body.
Even though the intelligence takes on the directing role in which the will of man resides,
look at the piece of information given to you there that the will of man resides in
the intelligence, okay, do you see it?
If he does not want it so, one can say that the eye does not see, the hand does not work,
the foot does not walk.
On the other hand, if he does want it, the eye sees the hand works and the foot runs.
All members place themselves in accord with the will understood, okay?
So it's the same with my divinity," he said, "my will takes on the directing role, and
all the other attributes place themselves in full harmony in order to follow up my will
once.
Therefore wisdom, power, knowledge, goodness, et cetera, they all concur.
And since all my attributes, although distinct among themselves, live in the fount of love
because God is love, one John four seven, and they overflow with love.
This is why while it is love that runs and acts and gives itself, all my other attributes
concur with it.
So what you have to say then is that wisdom overflows with love, wisdom that comes from
God, power that comes from God overflows with love, knowledge that comes from God over
flows with love, and all the rest as Louisa says, okay?
Now you can have wisdom and knowledge and power that comes from the world or comes from
the dark kingdom, okay?
And the thing that will be missing is love because we have too much evidence of human
beings being completely despotic about power and using power entirely for their own ego
and for their own advancement to the detriment of an entire nation or nations, okay?
So power used in the wrong sense is one of Satan's tools.
He uses three tools to pull down the human race, money, sex and power.
Nothing wrong with money if it's used properly, there's nothing wrong with sex if it's used
properly and there's nothing wrong with power when it's used properly.
And if money, sex and power are all used with love, then the human race is really advanced.
So what you're being shown here is that what comes from God, comes from love, is imbued
with love, gives love and therefore is a source of life, okay?
So for the rest of this section, it is the only motivation that is acceptable in divine
will is love.
And it is love that makes you like God, because God is love, because it's a very important
section here.
Furthermore, that which is most necessary to man is love, nobody can live without it.
Love is like bread for the natural life.
Bread there is a symbol of basic food, okay?
It's not bread as in bread and butter, it's the symbol of food.
One can do without science and power and wisdom or at most, these are things that one wants
in certain times and in special circumstances.
But what could one say if I had created man and he and did not love him, besides why create
him if I didn't love him, because God's logic is I am love and the only thing that makes
sense in the universe is love.
It would be a dishonor for me, a work unworthy of me, who can do nothing no other thing but
love.
That's terribly important and that is exactly the same as Sam 1 4 5 verse 17.
It can be a quotation from it, because Sam 1 4 5 verse 17 says God only ever acts out
of love, okay?
And what would happen to man if he did not have an origin of love and could not love?
If we were not made to love and couldn't love we'd be robots, wouldn't we?
And the most dangerous thing about this artificial intelligence is that they won't have love
and therefore they can do the most dreadful things, no problem.
You know they're making them into soldiers, do you?
So you put a gun or a machine into the hands of a machine that has no feelings and is told
to shoot, it'll shoot anything it sees, including the person operating the machine.
They're creating a monster and it's only when they put these monsters out they will
realize how monstrous it is and so the Lord says that if we couldn't love it would be
totally monstrous.
He says that man would be a brute and unworthy even to be looked at.
Therefore love must run in everything, all our thoughts, all our words, all our actions,
all our desires, absolutely everything, everything must be love, it's the only acceptable motivation.
Love should run in all human actions, we'd have no problems if people would love.
Just as the image of the king circulates in the currency of the kingdom, if the coins
were not marked with the image of the king they wouldn't be recognized as currency.
In the same way if love does not run in a work it is not recognized as my work.
Therefore there's a text in Matthew, I think it's chapter seven and it's somewhere after
verse twenty five where Jesus says that when the time of judgment comes that some people
will say Lord, Lord you walked on our streets, we ate with you, you know you can't reject
us and he will say I never knew you.
Because the thing that he condemned the Pharisees for in Matthew 23 was no love.
They had ritual, they had religion, they had the right garments, they had all kinds of
stuff but they had no love and he utterly condemned them because love is the only thing
they will get into heaven.
And that's the only currency we need doses of.
Okay so there's the emphasis on love which Jesus comes back to every now and then, I
noticed that he'll do it and then he'll do one or two volumes and then he'll come back
to it and he'll do another couple of volumes and then he'll come back to it and otherwise
this is the center piece and the whole thing.
So February the 21st, love makes one die and live continuously.
Now this is part of the mystery that people don't really understand.
Continue in my usual state, my adorable Jesus on coming told me, my daughter, my love towards
the creature made me die at every instant.
The nature of true love is to die and live continuously for the beloved.
Now in a non absolute sense the dying is that if you love somebody you will give your time,
you'll give your energy, you'll give your emotions, you'll give everything, so that's
the dying.
Okay and you're doing it all the time.
And so St. Paul gives a lot of space in his letters to dying to self, okay because love
can't live without that.
So if love is to live, somebody has to die, is that okay?
And somebody is the self.
The love of wanting her with oneself makes one feel death and causes a martyrdom perhaps
the most painful and prolonged.
However, love itself which is stronger even than death, that's a quotation from the song
of Psalms 8, 6, love is stronger than death and more terrible than Cheryl, okay?
So love is stronger even than death.
You see Jesus proved that on the cross because it was hell that had confronted him on the
cross and hell in all its disaster and terror confronted him and he was greater.
So love is more powerful than death.
And not only that but he came back to prove that he was more powerful than death.
So this love gives life at every instant in which it dies.
I remember my mother saying to us when I was young, I died nine times for you, people.
She had nine children.
She did have another one but the other one died.
But I always thought it was interesting.
The way she put it was I went down into death for nine of you.
So that is what you're being told here that love gives to the point of dying what it gives
life.
Somebody else receives life all the time from it.
So to give life to the loved one and to form one single life with her, those flames have
the power of consuming one life to fuse it with the other.
So he's talking about this deep contemplative love between the soul and God, that where
love is turned into a living flame, St John of the Cross has written a whole book on this.
This is precisely the power of my love.
To make me die and to form many seeds.
Now the many seeds that he has in dying is John 1224.
I'm like a grain sown in the earth that must die to bring forth the harvest.
So I form many seeds from my consummations, my sacrifice, my giving, my dying, to place
them in the hearts of all creatures.
Now in divine will, when you're praying for others, you're praying for everybody.
So is to make me rise again and form with them one single life with me.
So he dies and rises to get each one of the seeds, which is a soul to die and to themselves
and rise in him and we become one body, okay, the mystical body of Christ.
Now you too can die.
Who knows how many times for love of me and maybe at every instant, because in the divine
will you can do that.
Every time you want me and do not see me, your will feels at the death of my privation
and it doesn't reality.
In other words, this is not mystical as in up in the air.
Because as you do not see me, your will dies because it does not find the life that it
looks for.
So she lives with the not my will, but dying be done, okay, however, after it has consumed
itself in that act, I am reborn in you and you in me.
That's the resurrection side of it.
And you find the life you wanted, but to return to die once again in order to live in me.
In the same way, if you desire me, your unsatisfied desire feels death.
And as I make myself seen, it finds life again.
And so your love, your intelligence, your heart can be in the continuous act of dying
and living for me.
If I have done this for you, it's only fair that you do it for me because it's love on
both sides and in the divine will our love is being raised to the divine level.
So every act of self denial, every act of sacrifice, this is the dying for the divine
life to rise in us, okay.
So February the 24th, 1922, this is where the Lord said to Louisa that when he took the
cross on his shoulders, he placed each one of us inside of it.
So he decided what size our cross was going to be.
As I was in my usual state, my adorable Jesus made himself seen in the act of taking up
his cross and placing it on his most holy shoulders.
Now I want you to watch the word shoulder in this message.
And he said to me, my daughter, when I received the cross, I looked at it from top to bottom
because you get that in the arse of the passion as well, don't you?
To see the place where each soul would take in my cross, because when we have a cross,
we're not inclined to think that it's a bit of his, we're inclined to say, poor me, life's
hard on me until we miss both the mystery and the grace.
So among so many of them, I looked with moral love and I paid a more special attention to
those who would be resigned and who would live in my will.
It's the bit what the shoulder now and people who live in the divine will.
I looked at them and I saw their cross long and large, just as mine, because my will made
up for all that their cross lacked, making it longer and larger than mine.
If I can put it this way, there's more of us than him, okay?
So how long your cross stood out so very long because of the many years of bed and suffered
only to fulfill my will.
My cross existed only to fulfill the will of my celestial father and yours to fulfill
my will.
You're doing it only for me and that's the value of it.
One gave honor to the other and since both of them had the same measure, they blended
together, okay?
They were remembering the word shoulder.
Now my will has the power of softening hardness, of sweetening bitterness, of extending and
enlarging short things.
So when I felt the cross upon my shoulders, I felt the softness and sweetness of the cross
of the soul who would suffer in my will.
Therefore there's a special connection between us and the wound and the shoulder.
So when you're doing the hours of the passion and future, remember there's a special connection
between us and that wound, okay, which Louisa describes as so terrible that even his bones
were exposed, okay?
And my heart heaved a sigh of relief and the softness of the crosses of these souls made
my cross adapt to my shoulders, sinking so much into it as to cause me a deep wound,
which Louisa said exposed his bones, and although it gave me a sharp pain, I also felt the
softness and sweetness of the soul who would suffer in my will.
Now notice the sweetness and the softness has nothing to do with the shoulder.
Let's do it, the spiritual reality of those who would carry their cross in the divine will.
And since my will is eternal, their suffering, their reparations, their acts ran within each
drop of my blood in each wound and in each offence.
That's amazing, isn't it?
Their suffering and their reparations and their acts ran within each drop of my blood, each
wound and in each offence.
My will made them as though present at the offences of the past from the moment of the
first man sinned at the present and the future offences.
That's your PPF past, present and future.
They were the ones who returned the rights of my will to me.
And for love of them, I decreed redemption.
Look how important it is to live in the divine will.
It is for love of them, the people who would live in the divine will, he said that I decreed
redemption.
That's absolutely amazing, isn't it?
And if others enter into it, it is because of these souls that they partake in it.
There's no good which I concede, either in heaven or on earth, which is not because of
them.
That little piece really needs to be taken out and put on a little card or something
separate from the book so that you look at it frequently and realise how important it
is for us to live and act in the divine will because everybody else is dependent on it.
Isn't that amazing?
Okay.
So February the 26th, 1922, I was thinking about the great good that blessed Jesus had
done to us by redeeming us and he all goodness said to me, my daughter, I created the creature
beautiful, noble with eternal and divine origin, full of happiness and worthy of me.
Now it's only when you get to read and study the messages on the creation of Adam and all
that the Lord did for him that you'll appreciate this fully.
Okay.
So what if you just put grace in the margin there?
Because he's talking about the grace, himself pouring himself out in all these gifts and
carisms.
So the next sentence then is sin because that's the comparison here.
Sin ruined him from top to bottom, it made him decay from his nobility, it deformed him,
it rendered him the most unhappy creature unable to grow because sin stopped his growth.
You see, that's the kind of teaching we've got to give to people.
Sin stopped his growth and covered him with wounds such as to be repugnant from the mere
sight.
Now we know that when Jesus redeemed man that by the time Jesus hung on the cross he was
a perfect picture of sin, covered in wounds from head to foot and he was nailed, he was
a slave, he couldn't move.
So it represented the slavery of sin.
He was blinded by his blood, sweat and tears, so it represented the blindness of sin.
He was deafened by all the pain in his head and all the insults thrown at him, so it represented
the deafness of those who are in sin and unredeemed.
And so all the miracles that Jesus worked to heal others are illustrated on his body
that he took that leprosy to himself.
He took the blindness to himself, he took the deafness to himself, he took the dumbness
to himself, he took absolutely everything because that was his way of reversing the
thing permanently and allowing us to live a new life.
And that's given to you in one tiny little section here, my redemption ransomed the creature
from sin.
To ransom is to pay a high price, okay?
And my humanity acted just like a tender mother with her newborn.
Since there was no other food with which she can give life to the baby, she opens her breast
and attaches her baby to it and from her own blood converted into milk.
She administers to him the nourishment to give him life.
We have the stork, of course, as the great image of that.
It's Pelican, sorry, not the stork, Pelican, I wrote down stork, what was I thinking of?
Because everything is, sorry, I don't know what I was thinking of, because everything
out there in creation speaks the gospel to us and speaks godness.
He says it's all there, all you've got to do is read it, you know?
So the Pelican will do that.
So she administers to him the nourishment to give him life.
So that means as a sacrifice to yourself, even if a poor mother hasn't got enough to
feed her children, she'll leave herself without food to feed the children.
It's the same principle, okay?
More than a mother, my humanity let many holes be opened in itself with the blows of the
lashes that's discouraging, which almost like many breasts sent out rivers of blood so that
my children by attaching themselves to them might suckle the food to receive life and
develop their growth.
With my wounds, I covered their deformities, rendering them more beautiful than before.
Because that's the amazing thing about the Lord is he doesn't patch.
He only creates, okay?
And if in creating them, I made them like clearest and noble heavens.
Now, this is something you're going to have to remember for the higher volumes, okay?
I created them like heavens and I decorated them in redemption like stars because he's
going to presume you'll remember that and in the higher volumes he'll simply talk about
heavens and stars inside of you, okay?
So I made them like clearest and noble heavens and in redemption I adorned them, studying
them with the most refulsion stars of my wounds so as to cover their ugliness and make them
more beautiful.
To their wounds and deformities I attached the diamonds, pearls and jewels of my pains.
So notice we are recreated like heavens, okay?
And that we are absolutely healed with his wounds and then we're pearled by his diamonds
and his pearls and other jewels.
In order to hide all their evils and clothe them with such magnificence as to surpass their
state of origin, okay?
Don't look at the next sentence, it's fascinating.
Therefore it is with reason that the church says, "Oh, happy fault."
When did she say that?
Holy Saturday night, okay?
Oh, sin of Adam, oh, happy fault, the brought was so great a redeemer, yeah, Saturday night.
So it is, I love the way the Lord actually, the quotes of the church are quotes one of
the saints are quotes of the scriptures and you would think he wasn't the Lord of all,
do you know what I mean?
Because with sin came redemption and of course the redemption totally surpassed what happened
in the sin.
And my humanity not only nourished them with its blood but clothed them with its own person
and adorned them with its own beauty.
But now my breasts are always full to feed my children.
What will not be the condemnation of those who do not want to attach themselves to receive
life to grow and have their deformities covered?
So everything has been provided and you can see that why he identifies the human race
is completely ungrateful and he is saying that, you can see that we are completely ungrateful,
but look at the judgment that comes to those who refuse it.
That's the little bit that people don't want to know today.
As soon as you die everybody is sanctified today, you know, and you go to heaven automatically,
how they manage to get that one I couldn't tell you.
But the Lord himself denies that.
Okay, so March the 1st, 1922.
Jesus is chained by the soul who does his will and the soul by him.
Now he's using an image here which is a chain and he's introducing it to something that's
going to elaborate on in the higher volumes and that is when you do reach the point of
being in the divine will 24, 7, 3, 6, 5 and you're not going back to the old self.
In other words, you really made the final step, then there's no going out of it.
And so initially he's using the term chain, in other words, you will be bound by that.
That's why I often say to people, don't say the consecration prayer until you're ready
because there are words in there that you mightn't be ready for.
But say it, when you're ready it will make an enormous difference to your life.
I was very afflicted because of the privation of my sweet Jesus and then after much struggling
he came and from his wounds he made his blood flow over my breast and over my neck.
As these drops of blood fell on me, many of the brightest rubies were formed from each
drop of blood which made the most beautiful ornaments.
Jesus looked at me and said, "My daughter, how well that necklace of my blood suits you
and how it embellishes you, you look yourself, look how beautiful you are."
And then Louisa said, "But I was a little hoppy because he made me way too long."
Now it's not typical of human beings.
You get this incredible gift given to yourself, well you could have come yesterday, you know.
It's unbelievable isn't it?
So Louisa says, "My love and my life, oh, how I would love one of your arms clasped
around my neck as a necklace."
In other words, you keep these other ones.
We're unbelievable aren't we?
Yes, this would delight me because I would feel life and I would cling to it so tightly
that I would let you escape no more so she brings in the subject of chaining him.
Your things are beautiful, she said, "But I prefer you."
That's actually a very interesting thing that she's doing and she's actually right.
I remember having to reach out to try and help a person to recover.
She had been extremely damaged because her mother was ashamed of her being born because
the mother was in her 50s and everybody was saying, "My God, how could you give birth
to a kid in your 50s?"
And so the mother hid her in many ways and didn't allow her to have a normal life but
she gave her material things and by the time I met this lady she was ready to commit suicide
quite literally and so she had to be recovered step by step by step.
So Louisa is right in saying, "Your things are nice.
I prefer you."
I think it's a moment of insight for us all when we would realize that a hug or a little
bit of love is an awful lot better than lots of material things, isn't it?
We get that from God, it doesn't just come from ourselves.
Your things are beautiful, it's true, but when you detach them from yourself and I don't
find you, I don't find life and in spite of your things my heart raves, agonizes, bleeds
with pain because you are not with me and she's talking to him, seeing him, okay?
If you knew what torture you put me in when you don't come, you'd be very careful not
to keep me waiting so long.
Now you'd be pretty close to someone before you start threatening them like that and I
find it fascinating.
He seems to enjoy it, okay, and Jesus was all moved, you know, and surrounded my neck
with his arm and taking my hand and his, look at him coming down to exactly what she wants.
It's absolutely amazing, isn't it?
He said, "I know, I know how much you suffer and to make you content, here is my arm around
your neck as a necklace, aren't you happy now?
Know that I cannot do without making content one who does my will because as she breathes,
she forms the air of my volition around me in such a way that she not only surrounds
my neck but my whole life.
I remain as though chained and hampered by the soul within the very fortress of my will.
This will all be explained in much greater detail as we go into the higher volumes.
But this is far from displeasing me.
On the contrary, because of the great contentment that I feel, I hamper and chain her and others
I don't let you off either.
But that's typical of true love, isn't it?
It clings to the beloved.
If you cannot be without me, it's because of my chains, my shackles that hold you so
tightly that one moment without me is enough to give you a martyrdom of the most painful
child and she's always telling him that.
There's nothing that equals it.
Now Jesus did say to us in Matthew 11, 28 to 30, "Take my yoke upon you and learn of
me."
We've got to carry this yoke of his will.
So he said, "Poor daughter, you are right.
I will take everything into account, but I do not leave you."
That's Joshua 1.5.
And there's lots of other references, but I'll just give you that one because I gave you
all these, "I do not leave your references in volume one to four."
I enclose myself in you in order to enjoy the air of my volition.
Now look what he's looking for when he comes, he's looking for his own divine will, which
you yourself form for me.
That's by going into the divine will fusing.
In fact, the air of my will is your heartbeat, your thought, your desire, your emotion.
And in this air, I will find my support, my defense, and the most beautiful rest upon
your breast.
So he couldn't have become incarnate unless Blessed Mother was totally in the divine will
from the moment of our conception, because God can only come into his own environment.
Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter there.
So he's coming to us more and more and more as we fuse and live in the divine will.
Okay.
So March the 3rd, he uses the same imagery that he uses in the gospel for sowing the seeds
of his word.
And I give you Matthew 13 verses 4 to 7 for the parable of the sore.
There's an explanation of it later on in the chapter.
So continuing my usual state, my sweet Jesus came, but without saying anything, all taciturn
and afflicted to the summit is usually an awful lot going on on the earth when that's
when he comes like that.
So Louisa said, what is it Jesus that you don't speak?
If you are my life, your word is my food.
That's what Jesus is going to pick up.
And very often he waits and let's hear say something and then picks up on that and teaches
her.
And I cannot fast, you see, I can't fast God's word.
I'm very weak and I feel the continuous necessity of food in order to grow and maintain myself
strong.
Now he's going to give a first answer to that in this text.
But as you go on in the volumes, he's going to go deeper and deeper into it to the point
of telling you that if you, that's us, want to keep growing in the divine will, you have
to keep reading this material, you have to keep studying it, you have to keep praying
it.
That's the only way you'll get the grace to actually do it.
So there are three foods given to us.
The first food is the word of God.
That was the manna given in the Old Testament, the word of God.
The second food is the Eucharist and the third food is prayer, those three.
The first food is the word of God.
The second food is the Eucharist and the third one is prayer.
All three are incorporated into the Mass, okay, just so that we realize that the Mass
is actually a very complete experience when we enter into it.
So all goodness, Jesus told Louisa, my daughter, I too feel the necessity of some food.
And after I have nourished you with my word, that same word chewed by you.
Now there's the problem that you meet with in the parable of the sore.
Most of them don't chew God's word, they don't give much attention to it.
Being converted into blood, what does blood mean, it means life, for the Jewish people
blood is life.
It makes food for me, germinate, he's going to explain that now.
And if you cannot fast, neither do I want to fast.
I want the return of the food that I gave you.
And then I will come back again to nourish you, I feel very hungry, hurry, let me satisfy
my hunger.
Louisa said, I remain confused because I didn't know what to give him since I have never
had anything.
But Jesus with both hands took my heartbeat, my breath, my thoughts, my affections, my
desires.
Now when Jesus told her, he wanted her to feed him, she gave the same reaction as the
little drummer by, at the crib, do you remember, I have nothing to give him, therefore I'd
sing him a song, okay, or I'll beat my drum for him.
So he says, you have your heartbeat, you have your breath, you have your thoughts, you have
your affections, you have your desires, which had turned into many little globes of light,
that is divine will.
You are a prayer that we ask the Lord to breathe in my breathing and all the rest of
it, okay?
So the divine will turns everything into light because God is light, one John one five, God
is light, and it is as globes of light that God can absorb them, and he's using the imagery
of food that he feeds on them, is that okay?
Saying, this is the fruit of my word, these are my own things, it is right that I eat them
or that I absorb them and all the rest of it, okay?
On the next paragraph he says, but I have to work the soil of your soul, okay, as a terribly
important paragraph, terribly important, that as soon as the Lord sees that we're serious
about living in the divine will, he goes to work in us, and if we don't stop him, Philippians
one six will happen, and Philippians one six says that he will complete the work that he
starts, if we don't stop him, is that okay?
So, then he seemed to take a little rest, and afterwards he added my daughter, now it
is appropriate that I get down to work again, to work the soil of your soul, so it's not
all acts, he has to do an awful lot inside of us as well.
So as to be able to sow the seed of my word with which to feed you, now when a person
is starting out the spiritual life, people in divine will are not starting out the spiritual
life, you're much further on, but when people are starting, if the Lord wants to sow the
seed of his word on forgiveness, there may be a huge block, because there's a big heart
in there that doesn't want to forgive anybody, and it can take years before I let go and
receive the word of forgiveness that will actually heal me, and my forgiveness will
heal others, okay?
Now when you're in the divine will, that should all be past tense, okay?
So the work that he has to do now is to make sure that the self is not hiding in corners
and a sapping up divine will, and it's now really divine will, you know what I mean?
That you're saying words, but the action isn't there.
So he's got to do an enormous amount of purification in us.
Now of course, if you had arrived at Union with God before you came into divine will,
a lot of this would be short circuses, because that work would have been done before you
get to the Union with God, is that okay?
But most people are not at that like that, and so the move into Union with God and into
divine will is at the same pace, and therefore he has to do a good lot of work to purify
the will, to purify the intellect, to purify the memory, to purify your desires, to purify
your motivations, he's got to do a lot, and the trials and the difficulties that he allows
you to go through do that work if you allow it to do it.
So I need to work the soil of your soul so as to be able to sow the seed of my word with
which to feed you, I act like a farmer when he wants to sow in his field.
He forms little trenches, makes the furrows, and then casts the seed into them.
That was how they did it in Israel in his day.
And then he again covers the earth with earth, the little trenches and furrows in which he
has sown his seed, so as to keep them sheltered and give them the time to germinate.
And the Lord is very patient, he gives us time, and he knows with some things that are trigger
points for us that you need more time than for other things.
Like if you have been grievously hurt in your childhood, you know, you'll trip over a couple
of things, you won't trip over if that didn't happen, is that okay?
That's just the first example I could think of.
So he gives the time to germinate, and then he comes to harvest them increased to a hundred
fold.
Now look how much he's looking for, a hundred fold, and to make them his food.
But he is careful not to use too much earth, he's very, very interesting here that if you
plant the little seeds too deep in the soil, the weight of the soil can kill them, and
the weight of water in the soil can actually kill them.
And so this is a very delicate point here.
But he's careful not to put too much earth, and you're going to hear what the earth is
in a minute.
Otherwise it would cause the seeds to suffocate and die under the earth, and he would run
the risk of remaining on an empty stomach, in other words instead of a hundred fold to
get nothing.
That's the way I do it.
I prepare the little trenches, I form the furrows, I enlarge the capacity of our intelligence,
we need to underline that in green, white, and gold, because one of the things that the
Lord begins to tell you and will tell you more and more as you go on, that we're too
small, our capacity of soul is too small to take what he wants to give us.
So what he does is if you're willing, he will increase your capacity.
Remember he said to him who has more will be given, okay, and if you allow him to increase
your capacity, all your understanding of all this thing suddenly takes a different level
because you've shifted a level.
And when you operate on that level, then he wants to give you something more, he will
again expand the intellect until you stop or you die.
And so one of the things people don't realize is that people growing in divine union, actually
their IQ grows hugely, their knowledge, their understanding, their wisdom, all of that mounts
up to IQ, is that okay?
And if that's not happening, there's something stunting the growth, okay?
So I enlarge the capacity of our intelligence to be able to solve my divine word because
if he doesn't enlarge the intelligence, we may not have arrived at a place in which to
understand what he's saying, does that make sense?
But what he actually tells us in the higher volumes is that if you come across a message
that you personally don't understand, just keep going because the moment hasn't come
to increase your capacity to get it.
And the next time you go back to that, you'll have it.
But not to stay blocked at something, which is very, very interesting.
So he wants to be able to give more of the divine word and therefore form the food for
me and for her.
Then I covered the little trenches and the furrows with the earth.
Watch this, which is humility, nothingness, the annihilation of the soul.
Wow, isn't that fantastic?
And you need to put some kind of a little ring or something around the end, some little weakness
or misery of hers, I absolutely love that.
I absolutely love that.
He, most of the journey, he actually leaves you with little bits of stuff that you trip
over and you keep on saying, "God, I'll never get anywhere."
I slip on the same banana skin all the time, but what you don't realize is that banana
skin is actually giving you the humility to throw yourself on him and to rely on him
completely.
And the banana skin is nothing to him.
Notice he said, "I throw in a little bit of weakness here and there."
It's terribly important.
And it's the saint, because he really wheezes at saying it all the time, "I try him the
worst.
I'm bad.
I'm whatever, whatever."
And she's just aware of her weakness and her human misery.
And that's what keeps us humble and throwing into your nothingness.
I read a lovely thing in Maria Valtortes, Volume 1, was it last night or the night before,
where it was the time when Jesus took his mother and his mother's sister-in-law, Mary
of Clopus.
He took them out on mission for the first time, just the two of them.
He was breaking all the rules of society.
Women did not do anything in public.
Women only lived in the home and their job was just only in the home.
They had no public function, or as they say, unless you were all the wrong women, like Mary
of Magdalene.
She was well known.
And so it was a horrendously big thing to leave home and to travel with 13 men, which
was also breaking all the social mores of the day.
Everybody would sort of wonder, "Well, an Earth was going on."
And so in one of the houses where they stayed for hospitality, the woman in the house said
to Blessed Mother, "How do you cope with the stresses and strains of this when it's
challenging society to the level that it is?"
Blessed Mother never even hesitated.
She said, "I throw myself into my nothingness and let God have his way."
I thought, 100 percent.
And she said, "No more than that."
She stopped.
"I throw myself into my nothingness and let God have his way."
Well, this is what the Lord is saying to us here, that the nothingness and the annihilation
of the soul, that's the handing over of the eagle.
And it throws in a little bit of weakness, which I think is very interesting.
This is the Earth, and it is necessary that I take it from her because I lack the Earth.
He doesn't have that.
He's all spirit now, okay?
And so I cover everything and I wait for my harvest with joy.
Now, notice that little bit of misery doesn't bother him in the slightest.
Have you noticed?
Yeah, please do notice because we give too much attention to the little miseries.
And so do other people as well.
Here she is and she's saying she's all holy and she's just as impatient as anybody else,
simply because it didn't hold her mouth at that time.
Other people do that because if they see that you're trying to live a spiritual life, they
are presuming you're transformed overnight.
That's because they don't want to know the process.
And so they throw off this smokescreen.
It's very interesting.
So when the soul feels, watch this now, this is the warning bit.
When the soul feels her miseries, her weaknesses, her knottingness, and she afflicts herself.
She thinks about it and it goes to waste time because the little misery is thrown in there
as part of the ingredients to make the proper cake.
And if she gives attention to her miseries and her weaknesses and her distat in the other,
who comes in, the enemy comes in to create disturbance and discouragement and despondency.
Now that's the heavy weight of soil, can't you see that that heavy weight of soil would
destroy any seed?
And you notice that the person is caught up in themselves.
All this is earth in excess over the seed.
It's most beautifully put up there.
I just haven't seen it put so well anywhere else.
Oh, how my seed feels itself dying, how it struggles to germinate under this earth.
With all that negativity, of course, it feels it couldn't grow.
Many times these souls tire the celestial farmer and he withdraws.
In other words, if you're going to wallow in your negativity, you're on your own because
negativity has to do with the kingdom of the world and the kingdom of Satan, it's nothing
to do with the kingdom of God.
And yet we can be really troubled with negativity, can't we?
We can be really trying.
One of the things you've got to treat as enemy number one is negativity, you've got to get
out of it.
No matter how hard it is, you've got to get out of it.
And if you can't get yourself out of it, just cry out to the Lord and say, "Get me
out of here."
So how many are the souls such as these?
They wallow in their own sins or weaknesses or whatever because that means you're giving
too much attention to yourself.
Whereas what's the instinct of a small child, if they cut the knee or whatever, is to run
to the mommy, "I mean, and you get a kiss and it's all done."
It's a pity they don't keep the magic of kisses all their lives, isn't it?
Okay.
So Louisa said, "Am I one of these?
Like are you giving out to me?"
He said, "No, because Louisa still doesn't realize that all of this is for us, for generations
coming after her."
She doesn't realize that.
"No," he said, "One who does my will is not subject to being able to form earth that
suffocates my seed, and because you're lifting yourself all the time up into the divine will."
But there are many times I find not even humility in her, only her nothingness.
Now do you understand that?
Because nothingness is lower than humility, okay?
Which produces little earth and I can place just one layer over my seed and therefore the
seed will grow.
The sun of my will quickly fertilizes it and it germinates.
And I make great harvests and then quickly return to sow my seed again besides you can
be sure of this.
Don't you see how often I return to sow the seeds of truths in your soul, okay?
And he has told her a number of times that sometimes when he has been away for a bit
of while, she said, "What have I done wrong?"
And I was waiting for you to put it into practice, "Uh-oh, how long would you wait for us?"
Okay, I was waiting.
He said, "I wouldn't give you another one until you put that one into practice."
So as he was saying, this sadness appeared on Jesus' face.
Taking me by the hand, he carried me outside of myself and showed me deputies and ministers.
Now we've gone into a different subject, okay?
All distraught as if they had prepared a big fire and were wrapped in its flames themselves.
One could see sectarian leaders, this is Italy, and it's 1922, so the sectarian leaders have
to be communists and/or Freemasons, probably both, who tired of waiting before railing
against the church wanted either to be left free to wage bloody wars against it or to
withdraw from the government.
They felt the ground missing from under their feet because of financing, as well as other
things.
So the Lord has many ways of stopping people, and one of them has not let the finance get
out.
And in order not to make a bad impression, they wanted to withdraw from holding the lot
of the nation.
But who can say everything?
You see, she's still at it, she's supposed to say everything.
And Jesus all sorrowful said, terrible, terrible is the preparation, okay?
They want to do things without me, John 15, 5, without me, you can do nothing.
That is nothing good.
And everything will serve for their confusion, okay?
Now March the 7th is a really, really good lesson in which Jesus helps Louisa to discern
what's going on inside of her.
And what's going on inside of her is so unusual that the priests who are guiding her also need
Louisa to show them how to do it, do you know what I mean?
And so I want to give you, first of all, before we read anything, Matthew 7.25 by their fruits
you will know them, because that's actually what Jesus says to her.
If a tree produces apples you don't call it a banana tree, 7.25 by their fruits you will
know them.
I was thinking about what has been written, what we've just said.
And I said to myself, is it really Jesus who speaks to me or is it a trick of the enemy
or my own fantasy?
Now she's absolutely right to ask those questions because she's claiming that she sees Jesus
on a daily basis.
Now no other saint ever claimed that.
The claim is so outlandish that nobody would be inclined to believe her, okay?
And I mean when the church got this stuff given to them they were totally shocked at
the level of contact this woman had with Jesus.
So and Jesus oncoming told me, now watch this, my daughter, my words are full of truth and
light, John 14, 6 for the truth and 1 John 1, 5 for the light, okay?
So you'll recognize God's word by truth and light and they carry with them the substance
and the virtue or the power of trans, that should be power, okay?
And they carry the power of transforming the soul into truth itself and into light itself.
So if the result of having this message given to you transforms you into truth and life,
then you know you're being transformed into God, is that all right?
Interlight itself and into the very good which they contain.
In such a way that the soul does not only know the truth but she feels within her the
substance of operating according to that truth, do you see what he's saying here, that this
is not head knowledge, this is experiential knowledge, this is knowledge that is given
to you and you begin to live it, you begin to experience it, okay?
So and further my truths are full of beauty and attraction and in such a way that the
soul taken by their beauty lets herself be enraptured by them, now you very frequently
hear her that she's totally enraptured by what she sees or experiences.
So the very first piece of discernment Jesus gives her is that if something is from God,
God is light and God is truth.
Now we also know from these writings that light is the divine will, okay, and of course
the divine will is the essence of God anyway, okay?
And if what is given to you actually transforms you into truth and light yourself, then it's
God because Satan cannot give you truth and he cannot give you light, he is darkness and
he is lie and the world is deception, they can't give you anything either, okay?
So the second paragraph, in me everything is order, harmony and beauty.
So you'll get that in Ezekiel chapter one, Ezekiel chapter one, the harmony and beauty
of God's throne and everything around him is described and in Revelation chapters four
and five where the harmony and beauty of God's throne is described as well.
Now the only two places that even attempt to describe God's throne, see number one,
I created the heavens, they alone could have been enough but no, I wanted to adorn them
with stars almost studying them with beauty so that the human eye might enjoy more from
the works of its creator.
Now notice that the heavens and the stars were given for us, they weren't given just
to be there.
Now number two, I created the earth and I adorned it with many plants and flowers also
for us, I created nothing which did not have its own ornament and if this is in the order
of created things, how much more so in my truths, which of course is the divine order,
which reside within my divinity, okay, so that's the divine order.
So while it seems that they reach the soul, they are actually like solar rays coming
out from the source and penetrating the soul, which hit and warm the earth without ever
departing from the center of the sun and the soul remains so enamored with my truths
that she finds it almost impossible not to put them into practice.
So what's given is not just the truth but the power to live it.
That's where he's going to be saying to us as he goes higher and higher with us, my words
are creative.
So if his word is spoken into you and he says forgive, he has given you the power to forgive,
it's not just a command, okay, if he says love your neighbor, he has given you the power
to love your neighbor, it's not just a command.
So she finds it almost impossible not to put the truths that she has known into practice
even at the cost of her life.
On the other hand, when it is the enemy or the speculation of fantasy, they want to speak
about truths.
They bring neither light, watch this, nor substance, okay, nor beauty, nor attraction.
They are empty, really I'm surprised that the word truth is even used, they are, I would
say, empty words without life and the soul does not feel the grace to sacrifice yourself
to put them into practice.
Therefore the truths that your Jesus tells you are full of life and they contain my truths.
So beside that I want you to put John chapter 1 verses 1 to 4.
These life, light for all of us, life and light, okay, it's a beautiful passage isn't
it?
I'll do one more and then give you a break.
So Mark the 10th and this is a VIP one as well, many of these are VIP and this is that
if you're in divine will, everything is universal, it's not just for one individual.
Even if you pray for one individual, the same prayer has to be for everybody else as well.
So Louisa said, I was doing the hours of the passion and according to my usual way, I was
pouring myself into the holy will of God, offering them for the good of all.
That's a PPF, past, present and future.
But my will as though wanting to interfere very often would say, my Jesus in a special
way for help relief and liberation for a particular soul and she named them.
All of us have that instinct, haven't we?
Okay, that's going to be corrected.
And my sweet Jesus reprimanding me.
Now the reprimand wouldn't be given to you if you weren't in divine will, said, my daughter,
everything that one does in my will is like the sun which diffuses to all.
And as one praise in my will, offering my blood, my pains, my wounds, these convert
into as many rays of light which diffuse for all.
Now it's the all you need to keep encircling all the time.
They descend rapidly into the deepest present of purgatory and turn their pains and darkness
into light, therefore it can be the same for everyone.
And if there may be a difference, it can never be on the part of the one who gives, but only
on the part of one who receives.
The one who gives it's for everyone, not everybody will receive.
So the only difference is on the part of those who receive according to the dispositions
of each one.
So somebody just mightn't be willing right now to receive.
It happens as to the sun which gives light to everyone equally.
It hits and warms one point of the earth just like any other.
But who profits from this?
It's those who work.
That means the rest of the fields.
Which land produces fruit is the land in which seeds have been sown.
In other words, some lot are working and therefore they can benefit and somebody else
has sown seeds so the ground can benefit.
The other land in spite of the light of the sun remains in fertile because there's no
seeds to work on.
Therefore, distinctions do not exist in my will.
By itself it runs, it diffuses and it wants to give itself to all whoever wants can take
it.
Just like if the sun shines, you can go out and get yourself a tan or you can stay in
and stay the way you are, your decision.
It's not the decision of the sun.
So all divine will act are for everyone past, present and future and it's only at the other
end that there will be a difference.
Now Louisa said I remain deflected on hearing this because she likes praying for people
individually like everybody else does as well.
And Jesus said, "Ah, now watch this because this is very enlightening."
You would like to act like the sun if it wanted to concentrate its light and its heat
on one point more strongly.
Now you know that if you get a magnifying glass and let the sun concentrate on a particular
point, you can have a fire, can't you?
That's the sun giving all its power to one point.
This is what Jesus is referring to.
So it concentrates its light and its heat at one point more strongly.
To be able to warm it and illuminate it so much as to convert that point into the sun
itself, that is into fire.
Okay.
While it continues its regular course with everything else.
Ah, yes, Louisa, that's exactly what I was thinking about, you see.
It's the weight of gratitude that pushes me to do this.
So Jesus smiled, look at the way he was reading her, Jesus smiled and he said, "Well, if that's
the case, then go ahead and do it."
Now that's what what he's saying is that you at some point want to concentrate all the
divine will in such a way and to this person, that this person is completely transformed
into divine will.
He said, "You can do that one all right."
But you see, it's small little things that we just want to sort of concentrate on one
person.
You know, throw your seeds out absolutely everybody.
But if you want to concentrate everything on this soul so that this soul is completely
transformed into the divine will go, "Oh yeah, I like that one."
That's very interesting, isn't it?
So he said, "Oh, if that's the case, then go ahead and do it."
But you must know that since my will dominates everything is everywhere, sustains everyone,
out of the every all the time, and is known in heaven, it's known by the earth and even
by the demons, there's no one who kind of poses it.
In the same way, the soul who does my will must dominate everything, be everywhere, sustain
everything and I want her to be known by all.
Now one of the things I love about Louisa Picaretta is she doesn't let Jesus off with
a dot or a comma, she says, "No, but he knows me."
He said, "They will."
She couldn't even imagine it sitting in a bed all the time for sixty-four years, how
an earth could anybody know her and now she's known worldwide, isn't it amazing?
So Louisa said, "My love, I'm not known by anyone."
And he said, "What?
You are known by no one, all the angels in the saints know you, each and every one and
they anxiously await you're operating in my will like a divine note coming from the
earth."
She's the only one and the most harmonious one which flows over everything, they flows
over everything they have done in life to give them greater splendor and content because
the saints in heaven are allowed to benefit, to bring them up to that level, okay?
That's number one to all the saints in the angels know you.
Number two, the purging souls know you and they feel over themselves the continuous
refreshment that operating in the divine will brings.
Number three, the demons know you from the power of my will which they feel in you and
if the earth doesn't know you for now, it will know you later.
So that's number four, the earth will know you later.
It happens and I act with one who does my will just as I did with my celestial mother.
I constituted her queen of all and I commanded all to recognize her and to honor her as their
queen and I commanded her to crush with her foot the head of the infernal dragon.
So I do with those who live in my will everything is under their dominion and there's no good
which doesn't come from them, isn't that fantastic?
So I'm going to break there so we have a little time of discussion.